good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials and apologies
to the podcast listeners my voice sounds
as it feels which is shut no you have a
frog in your throat truly and what it
really is is that little pendulum that
hangs between your tonsils as well my
tonsils have gotten so big that they're
all three like two testicles and scrotum
it looks really hot back there between
the mucus beautiful well you're all
swole swole and this like of course this
was gonna be like another full week for
us but Mother Nature had other plans and
I apologize deeply and I felt so guilty
until I saw the true love that was
happening live on our screens and I was
like you know what God everything
happens for a reason God gave me this
strap so my sister could find the man of
her dreams unfortunately I don't think
there's been any movement since
yesterday's episode I was I didn't know
what was happening in the comments for
those of you who haven't watched
yesterday's episode yet I forgive you
but we had the lost Kings on snitch was
filling in for Claudia and apparently
there were sparks flying there was like
a legit a soap opera happening in the
top in the comments section and Margo
was the only one reading it but like she
felt awkward like she was doing
something they were like she's blush and
her and they said her in hat guy are
just gonna be mr. and mrs. hat
mrs. hat it's so funny mrs. snitch hat
here's an update on my health it's
slowly deteriorating I have a feeling
these will be my last few days on earth
which is so sad because I just booked a
bunch of sold-out shows I got a lot of
questions about Houston and Huntington
which both sold out I will be adding
shows for both so stay tuned but make
sure you're hitting up all the other
markets cuz a lot of them are about to
be sold out where I'm not gonna add more
shows like Orlando and Greenville and
Greensboro and Tampa so girls no job
home is a place to go out person to be
you know for sure for sure has CEO he's
been a very emotionally supportive a
little bit of a pain in the ass okay I
guess you don't really realize when
you're feeling fine like how much care a
dog takes cuz you're just like happy to
do it
but like when I can't even get up
seriously to pee like I cannot get up to
walk the oh did he say anything about
India he said that he was really
grateful for getting out of the house
because I've been locked
walked up inside he therefore has to be
locked up inside as well and now I've
become one of these people who takes
facial tissues with them so that's
really exciting for me that's better
than the alternative which is nothing
well honestly like if I ever run for
president which is never gonna happen I
hope to god that they don't get the
footage of me yesterday in my cab and in
the Duane Reade what did you do so and
you know what they can't hurt you with
it if you come out ahead of it so now I
would be tied to the doctor now would be
the time to come clean I went to the
doctor and I was feeling my absolute
worst yesterday morning and I couldn't
even move but I had to go to the doctor
again side go do the appointment come
back out and I'm in anywhere and he's
just wanting to like play music and left
such a nice guy what a jolly fella not
for me
and I was like can you please turn on
the heat I was heading having body
chills I was freezing and I guess I'm
with a normal person like the car was
warm and they put it up all the way in
the back and he like kept asking if you
could turn it out I'm like no I was
gonna go into it I'm like dude I'm sick
like you were with me for 20 minutes
sorry kept cracking his [ __ ] windows
well I'm freezing in the back with my
body chills started to cry in the car
like just I couldn't stop crying and
every time I was crying all day
yesterday but every time you cry like it
makes it so much worse because I'm like
her throat Wells up and you get water
and like mucus so as much as I would
like didn't want to cry I truly could in
the traffic holy [ __ ] I feel like we all
know how bad traffic in New York is and
how much of like and how like New York
is incapable incapable of getting things
done being you don't realize that when
every minute feels like two hours to you
so I was like I I neglected my health
and didn't go to the doctor two days ago
because I knew to get from my apartment
to the doctors but to be on the same
Avenue but it's just like two miles up
like would take me at least an hour and
it's it like that's so unsafe
jin-sang unsafe for me like what if I
was dying oh well then you call an
ambulance and they just call ambulances
anymore it's awesome five grand
they take uber to the hospital and in
the middle of the night two nights ago I
was literally in so much pain I was
thinking back or in the hospital and I
was like I'm not [ __ ] paying $5,000
it's not 5,000 yes it is offered
ambulance ya know you would uber to the
hospital and just pay the hospital bill
right but for my regular uber to get
there
he's unsafe but if he was in the middle
of the night you would have gotten there
maybe so whatever I'm like kicking and
screaming in the back of this uber and
then it takes a turn because there's no
no movement I get out I'm I'm freezing
and it's freezing and I walk to my
training ring and honestly I had just
come from the doctor and prescriptions
take time and she could see that I was
like dying because I was like visibly
crying in front of her and I was really
grateful that she like moved she could
tell something was wrong yeah she hauled
ass and like made the prescription but
like it wasn't fast enough like you
understand every minute being alive
yesterday was comparative to 6:00 and
normal hours so I'm like freaking like
under the counter like and it's like and
I'm literally sobbing she hands me a
receipt I blow my nose in it like it was
bad that's bad understandably bad and
you know what now that if you want to
issue an apology to whomever got in your
way then they can't use it against you
says you can still run I mean I was
visibly in pain and if you're not aware
of my feelings and that's your problem
okay very fair are you still contagious
I don't know so now I'm on the third day
of amoxicillin which really like breaks
down the bacteria but obviously it
doesn't make you feel better
trip is such a little [ __ ] and I threw
up like it was so shady I'm like hating
this whole thing called being life but
you're getting skinny I know okay that's
like the one silver lining yesterday and
the day before I didn't eat anything
except a milkshake and the milkshake
feels so good going down my throat like
I couldn't care I just wanted to like
literally got it from the first one I
got from a diner which was haagen-dazs
and it was delicious
the second one I got from Tasti D'Lite
and it tasted just like melted ice right
it was terrible but it felt so good I
was Lucia get a frosty from Wendy's no
those you can't suck it's like with oh
right maybe Mountain Allah I literally
just wanted to put the straw like on my
tonsil and suck in it felt so good and
then I had some consomme which I hate
soup but I'm not gonna lie
the consomme One Bowl of consummating
made me feel better then all my drugs
and all mad
- consomme like a known word it's a
Jewish word right I'm not sure because I
like where are the only people who call
it Chi Chi the Jewish penicillin
yeah and it's consummate it's just broth
but it's been like soaked with all these
vegetables and chicken chicken and beef
broth or whatever it took looks just
like pea but it's filled with nutrition
maybe it's not it let's see if everyone
knows yeah that's so weird to think
about if they don't you're missing out
well I'm glad you're able to join us
today thank you for your service well
I'm happy to be here but I'm mostly here
because I agreed to be on a career day
panel at my high school today so if I'm
gonna do that I'll do this - yeah just
morning I'm not gonna be good at either
of them that's okay we have some great
stories so that'll help you know Zhu Zhi
up the show um yeah I'm [ __ ] tired as
boss you didn't even think also to get
jealous last night
but have you not been watching TV
actually I just found out on my regular
TV that I have all the episodes of
Orange County so I'm still catching up
on Orange County and I'm loving it and
I'm not here for what anyone has to say
if it's bad oh you're enjoying the
season yeah usually it's like Orange
County they need to be built no so good
by the time they got to Jamaica it's a
fine season of housewives who took a
while to get there integrating the new
girls who's Emily who's Gina Gina
literally Emily looks like Jesus but
this dinner with Shannon was with the
most shocking thing ever she's out of
control she's out of control and as a
Shannon apologist it's my job gets
harder and harder no Shannon apologists
your job ends here know for sure she the
reunion is a little better for her but
still like not great okay anyways I was
talking about Dallas you have to watch
the reunions because last night was so
good they it was only a two-parter and
the second part is so good first of all
Cameron they did this whole thing on
Cameron remember how I said that when
someone's talking to her she's always
like nodding along like just in
agreement like encouraging them well it
turns out that's what she does when
she's spaced out and they did this whole
montage of her nodding along when people
are saying the craziest things oh my god
she looks like she's in agreement or
even like judging them and she was like
no that's what I do she said I had no
clue that way that I did it until I went
on TV right and it was still a anyways
well you were just talking now I'm so
spaced out I felt like Cameron I was
like it's almost better I was like why
can't a girl I don't know and maybe a
Dallas thing but I can always tell but
like I'm talking to someone in there
just straight up not listening so I
would feel a lot better if they still
weren't listening but they're just like
yeah yeah like she's a good friend now
she does heaven every single scene it's
so funny also you have to watch mom and
D is on it she's your purse she brings
her purse she's the queen of it she
calls it a pocketbook she's the queen of
England and she's so funny I need to go
watch all the old episode she is in
because it took me a really long time
for me to even care about her because
she said she didn't give a dog's rip
yeah she doesn't give a rip but also
like Deandra kind of brainwashed us
about her mom so I feel like now if we
watch it through the lens of like we
love them maybe it'll be for better TV
she's everything she said literally any
success there she came in every word out
of her mouth was a bit of gold she was
vomiting gold like a real housewives
all-star mom cast like but some on
Andy's favorites I don't agree Maris
walls mom yeah she is a charmer who
marge senior Marsh senior mama Dee there
are some good moms yeah well sue L by
the I ran in Josh Shapiro in
bloomingdales Jill zarin's daughter and
you know how their dog passed away they
got a new dog and Jackie you need this
dog what do you mean first of all the
dog probably weighed total two pounds it
was like so like Larry had the same hair
color as you so like a little furry I
forget what it's called like a Moroccan
whatever but his face like underneath
all of his fur was just like so
delicious and pure and he smelled good
and I was like where did you get this
dog I'm gonna have to ask her because
I'm she's really like a Paris Hilton
Chihuahua I like but I'm not gonna lie I
babysat Theo yesterday and then me me
rethink
like my path to getting a dog not
because he was nothing but a sweet angel
boy but one like he really smelled bad
and his dog breath and like it was just
a smelly brother I gave him the bath the
second I got home it was a smelly day
and I used kids
no tears watermelon L'Oreal shampoo
memories to use that he smells so good
right now
young - so I'm my the one reason why I
really can't get a dog yet is because
I'm still afraid to like go into their
mouths when they're chewing on ice so
when I had Theo yesterday I was using it
as a tester and I was like I gotta get
this out of his mouth or else I can't
have a dog and I think I've got one one
thing out of his mouth what yesterday I
was like feeling crazy it was the cap to
lash glue he oh yeah he loves a cap he
loves a cap anyways I got out of his
mouth and stuff yeah watch him then
three it was like any time he got off
the bed I had so much anxiety that he
was gonna pee on the floor that I would
just take him outside and then like we
were standing in the cold just because I
was like well 100 because he did
something so weird so I left your
apartment I walked to Bloomingdale's on
the way to Bloomingdale's he peed then I
left I was in Blooming the house five
minutes because I was shopping for hats
and don't do that with the dog by the
way I like literally at the leash
between my it was wrong and he was not
being helpful I'm not giving me any good
feedback okay I was in Blumenau for five
minutes left Bloomingdale's to walk home
and he pees again so he peed like twice
in the span of 10 minutes and I was like
oh he's all [ __ ] up maybe has a UTI
maybe he needs you chorus no maybe maybe
you pulled him too hard I'm around look
he wasn't done peeing but he's just like
I know that that wasn't the case but he
really uses his timeout wisely like he's
out cuz for me he's like I know this
[ __ ] isn't getting that for another
four hours let me get it all out out
that wouldn't alarm me at all okay it
was new and a bit alarming who would
ever know how's your voice that you're
sick I don't know why try except that
girl someone literally tweeted at me
like I saw please stop singing like for
the love of God you're ruining the toast
and I'm like do people really feel that
way because I'll stop but I really think
that people like it so I really don't
think people feel that way well the
people in the comments are like would
the best toaster watching right now are
like stands but if you listen to this on
the podcast and you really hate that I
say please let me know say it in a nice
way though and then I'll stop until then
new and a bit alarming who'd have ever
thought that this could be
[Laughter]
better worse great and it's I mean your
voice is always great I'm a little bit
of a softer tone do I stick a shoe look
usually you're very ah we can I say
something funny now I watch friends
through the lens of like what Jackie
think this is funny okay and I've seen
this episode now twice in the past like
month where I'm like this moment Jackie
will think it's funny I send it to me
or can I just like give you know because
every time you set up the scenario it's
funny but if you want to convince and
like give me one episode because I
watched massive people the episode sucks
what the Massapequa episode no no no the
episode kind of explaining this okay
okay
so Monica you have to pick one friend
fire Monica and Chandler are married now
and she bought like a really expensive
pair of boots and she comes home and
shows them and he's like freaking out
it's like more than their rent and she's
like please like their 90's cute okay
they're like black knee boots with a
little heel and they're like alligator
yeah and she's like please please please
like I can wear them all the time
they'll go with skirts shorts dresses
like it doesn't matter I can wear them
anywhere this and he's like fine so
after wearing them one day like they're
so painful it's like she can never
really forget and she's outside her
apartment
putting her sneakers back in her bag and
putting the boots on pretended like she
wear them all day and she comes inside
and chairs like hi don't forget we have
my holiday party company holiday party
she's like oh we really have to go to
that and he's like well I guess but he
was silver lining you can wear your new
boots and she's like oh no I don't want
to
he's like why he said they go with
everything and she's like well I just
don't think your boss is to think that
you're getting paid too much and I don't
want your assistant to think that she
getting deserves a raise and he goes do
you think I work at some boot pricing
company every time I hear it I'm like
that's funny and Jackie would think
that's funny
could be like we're still like a
statistical data process or whatever
janya work at some companies so there
wasn't like the nuggets of friends I
like make it what it is but then there's
the moments where Rachel's just being
such a bad actress that I get almost
ruins the show okay I understand and I
really did enjoy Massapequa but I only
liked when Alec Baldwin was on this
course
and he is a guest star everyone else was
still being annoying this [ __ ] totally
Paul Rudd
who is a guest star but like for many
seasons as Phoebe's boyfriend eventually
husband he's a great addition
cuz he's like rich on the Upper East
Side and she was homeless for a brief
period of time and she used to mug
people for a living so a lot of the
parts of it is funny but now I do look
at it through this critical lens like
was it worth a hundred million and it
was just like for me but the show is
it's because sometimes I watch it I'm
like this sucks but then sometimes I'm
like that it's funny that's the stuff
yeah so it's a little bit about honestly
Rachel Green like pretty much her a show
just cuz she's the worst character and
the worst actor it's like there's this
scene and I'll show you this but she's
like planning on telling Ross said she
loves him and she says it and then
starts like hysterically laughing but
it's like the worst fake laugh I've ever
heard is she's like he's like are you
kidding why are you laughing like watch
and I was like what the [ __ ] is he
talking about like it was so stupid that
doesn't sound like friends that sounds
like Lena pana Horvath no it sounded
like Lauren Michaels got up in there and
wrote a scene it was so stupid that's so
weird
honestly all the stuff with the girls
isn't funny like Chandler and Joey and
Ross are so funny speaking of Lauren
Michaels
um and SNL and Jason Momoa I haven't
watched his episode yet but have you
seen that that story is circulating
again mama-mama
for those who don't know this is like an
old-school breath Orochi toaster story
and cuz Jackie likes dams Jason Momoa
and I jus - don't get me wrong he's so
he's like my number one celebrity crush
right if you're ever at a party and they
ask you who your celebrity crush is
she's never got like a Hall Pass right
and I love him too cuz like Khal Drogo I
love it but there's like a small part of
me that like can't get over his
relationship with his wife Lisa Bannon
yeah because elusive and I sorry the way
he tells the story of how they like met
is so creepy he's like basically he used
to watch her on TV she was on the show
and he used to watch at home and like
point to her on the screen to his mom
and be like mama I want him that's
that's where how I heard him say it and
now every time I think of them as a
couple I'm like ma ma et phone home it's
like the weirdest thing it's the
weirdest thing
he told that story before I but now he's
an even bigger star he told it again
he's circulating and let's not forget
how serious and it's really weird and
that's all
speaking of Lisa Bonet Lenny Kravitz was
on watch what happens live last night oh
and he did a really good job I like get
the vibe that Lenny Kravitz is cool [ __ ]
he was really cool he didn't shy away
from anything the only questions he
liked couldn't answer he did plead the
fifth and like Sophia no he was down to
answer whatever but some of the
questions were like he had to like think
he needed time to think they were like
what's the craziest place you've had sex
and like he doesn't have that answer can
he he would have time to think of all
the years of sex it's a hideous place
you've had sex we've done this so Jose
oh my that's right yeah I know your
answer but not on the chose um you know
I'm really a comfort sort of girl but
crazy and comfortable a hammock oh yeah
yeah what about you oh the places I've
gone sweetie the ocean the ocean yeah
who are you Juan Pablo it was in Puerto
Rico and also the men's dressing room
they're so nice it's literally like a
suite with a couch and like a fridge
that's assumed opprobrium that's so yeah
well like I can do things like that it's
like I'm we're nice girls like I wasn't
and these lips have touched nobody you
know mm-hmm I'm a one-man woman I'm just
too much of a rule follower you know
yeah like that's what gives me anxiety
it's cool I can break you know but yeah
some people would say like that's the
thrill right I don't know anyways
are we ready to deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast yeah I guess I'm ready I
could use a little hot tea first but
other than that I'm fine
okay first story happy birthday Taylor
Swift and true Taylor Swift mode she's
getting back to the Swifties and sharing
a first look at her Netflix comfort
concert special sorry I bought that one
Taylor Swift's stadium reputation tour
is coming to Netflix on New Year's Day
okay here is what is so exciting about
this the one caveat I have is that it's
Olivia's wedding that day no but we're
going to be getting ready all day I'm
watching it no because it comes out
1200 the night before like it comes out
at 3:00 a.m. on the 31st for us oh my
god so we can watch a turn our glam yeah
oh my god I forgot I thought it was
January 1st so we have to make sure
that's what Olivia wants no offense I
don't care
oh my god I'm so no here's what the best
part about it is is that this lives on
Netflix forever so her 1989 World Tour
which is probably even if I say
reputation 99 will still be my favorite
you have to [ __ ] go on Apple music
there's nuts the only place to watch it
and I don't have Apple music so anytime
I want to watch it I make Apple music
and then cancel it so it's so annoying
but I'm a Netflix subscriber and
honestly if they had taken friends off
about giving me this I would say oh for
sure like that's what's so exciting said
I always have access to it some of her
[ __ ] is so hard to find like her 18
t-shirts up and her Super Bowl stuff her
DirecTV stuff like this is legit this is
mainstream how much should they pay her
thanks so much for all the birthday
wishes today I finally get to show you
something we've been working on for a
while the trailer for the reputation
stadium tour how much did they pay or
they must if they paid 100 million
dollars for friends I would think they
paid 100 million dollars from Taylor
Swift because they paid 100 million
dollars for friends just to keep people
happy this is gonna get them new
customers literally the people who
downloaded like the DirecTV Taylor Swift
channel like me you know so like this
will really AT&T u-verse with the
Millennials he and I think they might
have paid her more than a hundred
million yeah yeah sorry I thought there
was a number here but it's just about
her tour um I think it's so smart I'm
glad she's like stop trying to make
fetch happen with all these Rando cable
networks you know like AT&T DirecTV they
for a while she was all about the money
first now that she's built her empire
she can afford she can afford and I'm
glad that she's just taking the plunge I
mean this is so exciting and me and my
tumblr and my my swifty page like we all
we're anticipating it because every one
of her shows is highly filmed with like
high tech like movie equipment but they
all are and that doesn't mean we're
getting a movie because she is I think
every single one of her shows ever on
tape because she can afford to do that
so you think you see a cameraman with a
thing action it means movie but it
doesn't know it but also they're filming
because it goes up on the screens at the
same time so like they automatically
have a failed but it's just like her
method when it comes to either doing a
tour
vd or not is so interesting because she
did fearless and then I feel I speak now
hmm she didn't do read she did 1918 I
only she did read but it's like very
obscure like no it's me it's not that's
that's what I heard
cuz I [ __ ] bought it on Amazon and it
was some girls iPhone recorded for - oh
really yeah okay
there's no red if there is no but so
it's so it's just you think maybe she
does every other I don't know I don't
know either maybe just like when the
money's right or when she needs the
money or she's like pissed that she's
not the number-one earner this year of
female musicians and so now she is now
she is Wow
I mean for me on a J that is otherwise
really difficult for me this just like
gives me joy I think she knew that I and
happy birthday Taylor I love you so much
thank you for being a queen and
inspiration to all of us I just I'm so
proud of you and I love that you've
become this person cuz I love 1989 it
was my favorite era but I don't feel
like you were being authentic to
yourself like when you were just like
too skinny and like pretending to be
friends with Gigi Hadid like now you are
like living your life with your
boyfriend and your mom and you realize
what's important like not everyone is
trustworthy and that's an important
lesson to learn and I love you that was
really sweet I'm excited for the
commentary that like will be weaved into
the twice you know like what is with
guests no but like I'm sure there's
gonna be like behind the scenes stuff
we're gonna get to like we haven't seen
her like on a personal level and if I'm
so long so like I'm sure she's gonna
like do some interviews you know yeah so
1989 had a good mix of interviews behind
the scenes like her and hey making up a
dance - 50 cent it's getting hot it's
getting hot in here Nelly Nelly yeah
there was cute and then there was also
getting hot in here it is there was also
cute behind the scenes with the guests
and you have like little snippets of the
guest performances I made it to the
but that was back when every show had a
guess and like she was really like yeah
just kind of thirsty so now that there's
so few guests it's more about her there
was literally like what we had Mary
Morris we had a Kyoko Hayley kiyoko and
Troian try and Sugarland Troy Troy Troy
savants Sugar Land that guy know with
the old man to McGrath detail Tim McGraw
Faith Hill Robby something were they
saying something with Kings I don't know
angel los Kings no um
did anyone perform at the one that we
went to do anyone come out no very sad
there's one anyways very exciting Olivia
get ready get ready for like Olivia's
gonna like out of all of us Olivia like
care sleaze right but it's still gonna
be good background music yeah
and I just really still feel like we
need answers like where are you at you
know like where are you at mentally
physically emotionally and obviously
we're putting it out New Year's is
because the last song on her album is
New Year's Day yeah interesante speaking
of some more baking Netflix news next
Netflix reveals what's coming and what's
going in January 2019 and then it's so
disappointing both available on January
1st across the university Adams family
babble Black Hawk Down incredible movie
that should be it tells me we have the
beat but it's it's gut-wrenching it's
awful and it's not a happy ending the
boy in the Striped Pyjamas very sad City
of God comedians of the world The Dark
Knight
Definitely Maybe The Departed Godzilla
Happy Feet Heller high water
I know what you did last summer Indiana
Jones four versions of them it takes two
yes oh that's good oh my goodness that's
so exciting
Jay and Silent Bob strike back Jersey
Boys Mona Lisa smile mr. Bean's Holiday
The Mummy The Mummy Returns Pan's
Labyrinth Pinkie malenky pulp fiction a
series of unfortunate events even pylab
berlin's pinky-winky you're literally
The Strangers swingers tears of the Sun
tidying up with Mary condo Watchmen X X
X X X s State of the Union and then more
other crapola that I am NOT
honestly I haven't heard anything that
I'm really down for chicks to kimmy
schmitt last season part two as well the
way they did part one season was so
terrible agreed but it's good I actually
like when a final season is terrible
because then I won't miss it yeah
and also Sebastian Maniscalco stay
hungry oh I knew you'd be excited about
that aren't you embarrassed do you I
don't know what's leaving is it
everything game sort of Beethoven's
Christmas adventure we should play that
for Theo yeah blade blade to Catwoman's
face off fighting netherland Friday
Night Lights hmm don't tell snitch
Godfather Godfather Part II Godfather
Part 3 Green Mile how to Lose a Guy in
10 days I am Ali interview Guy in 10
days Law & Order Special Victims Unit
15th 17th and 16th years Love Actually
Marie Antoinette and Meet the Parents
Million Dollar Baby Princess Diaries
dup dup but what about Lilly Moscovitz I
don't know it's like they knew we were
about to serve justice for her and they
were like all the sharknadoes very sad
for the whole sharknado family very sad
for the whole Tara Reed family rent hmm
but we are getting rent live which is
exciting with I just have to say when
this time of year rolls around and you
see what we're losing and what we're
getting what you're getting has to
really make an impact based on what
we're losing and this is losing of all
the things I'm excited about that are
coming which is literally just it takes
two and and kimmy schmitt
encouragement like to be losing all of
that other stuff like that is not an
equal balance and thus someone who
believes in equal rights for all I'm
very disappointed I'm very disappointed
and I still like really don't understand
why things have to leave Netflix you
know it's licensing it's licensing but
if it's something like people really
enjoy can we keep it well so Princess
Diaries I'm assuming is a Disney movie
and Disney's coming out with their own
streaming service so there are a bunch
of companies that are now coming out
with their own streaming services to
compete with Netflix and I think that's
why so many are leaving
like what was spread in Night Lights on
NBC
CW no wb11 I don't [ __ ] know NBC
really know it was one of those teen
channels no wasn't for sure it was
whatever there's just like a million
they have CW
seed now but it wasn't on CW because I
watched CW seed commercials every day
because of the CW app it's the only way
I can watch over Dillon dynasty and they
haven't advertised it I have something
to say I have pretty much stopped
watching Riverdale okay because I
started this season and I love Riverdale
and I love like the people it's produced
and like that I get to follow on
Instagram and I'm fine with that like
the show is just not good anymore
if you're into like horror and sci-fi
it's a good show yeah and I'm not angry
and I like I hate feeling left behind
but my docket is so full and my
priorities now our Housewives and
reality shows and The Bachelor is coming
back like I can't take it all on
that's very thick you have to know where
cut dynasty is staying
I love dynasty that's like a true guilty
pleasure same with Blue Bloods but the
Housewives it's a lot of work I think of
them as like work and work has to take
priority I agree I'm enjoying Riverdale
like it's not to show that like I signed
up for but you know I'm on the list so
I'm just gonna keep watching and I also
now I'm curious what's gonna happen it's
like I'm more of like a purveyor what's
the word like just like well outside
looking at you know a perspective like
it's more of a voy voy or experience
okay I don't know okay next story Jarama
in the teen world holy goddess raising
did Hailee Steinfeld and Nik [ __ ] nice
Lawrence put it did they well that would
have meant that they had to be together
in a real way which I'm still not
positive about coming together like once
or twice she was wearing his t-shirt she
was wearing they like we're at each
other shows a little bit I think they
probably went on a couple dates for sure
but fans are heavily speculating that
they've broken up rumors we got in the
fall when they noticed the couple was
rarely photographed together but they
gained traction in November when the
bumblebee star was seen with her ex
boyfriend Cameron smaller
that'll do it the former couple appeared
in an Instagram story video of Republic
Records party which was uncirculated on
Twitter there have also been reports
that the former One Direction crooner
has joined the exclusive dating app Bria
which is described as tinder for
celebrities yep that'll do it well
here's the thing
the thing is
Hailee Steinfeld is truly like a
superstar like I follow her on Instagram
and she does so much no she does so much
but like everyone is sleeping on her
like the looks that she serves I
copal level I think she's one of the
best-dressed women in Hollywood I
literally look tag Margo and all her
pictures being like the [ __ ] like it she
has such great style she agreed as a
great stylist but you know what cheap
Haley hired her she owns a props to them
is always so good like her Instagram is
very curated very premium premium and
it's so funny though because Sarah
Hyland posted a picture of them too for
her birthday did you say and Hailee
Steinfeld is a different person like I
didn't recognize her she used to be like
such a nerd she had no upper lip and now
she is like huge lips yeah well whatever
she's doing keep on doing it and she's
like low-key in all these movies like
this and she's like she opened for Katy
Perry so she's like a full-blown pop
star and also like an up-and-coming like
big superstar movie actress I just feel
like one day everyone's gonna turn
around be like oh my god when did Hailee
Steinfeld like becomes so 11-million
list like she's on she's doing all the
work now it's like what you do in the
dark shows in the light or something
like that like she's working hard right
now in the day it's all gonna come to
fruition soon like she's hosting like
the MTV Movie Awards in like
Czechoslovakia like soon she was singing
her international business soon she'll
be hosting him here right
I wonder who her manager is they do good
work she's like Daenerys she's gonna
come back to the USA with an army
exactly I really like to just love her
and she every time I stumble upon her
Instagram I'm like damn why does nobody
talk about her I know I'm telling you
there's she's so legit they're sleeping
on her baby sleeping I recommend
following her on Instagram I've recently
just been starting to unfollow people on
Instagram because little bit really I
know if I'm gonna follow enews and
they're gonna do all the round ups of
wells and Sarah Hyland for me like I
don't also need to follow them I don't
need to see who is the same picture
three times
totally once is enough next story a
little business
so we're too early for a little business
Apple to invest 1 billion dollars in new
Texas campus
unlike Amazon like this is a decision
that is in tune Apple will invest 1
billion dollars in a new campus in
Austin Texas the company announced on
Thursday the 133 acre campus will be
located in North Austin amel accommodate
an initial 5,000 employees with capacity
for 15,000 employees in total apple also
announced plans to open new sites in
Seattle San Diego and Culver City
California over the next
year's cute here for here for creating
jobs I was just going to say I love when
companies just make jobs make jobs in
cities that aren't New York City yeah we
just couldn't need where everyone has
jobs and there's no more room for people
who don't have jobs right I can't I
still I can't believe Amazon's coming
here I can't believe it like I'm so
accept but this makes me happy that
someone's doing the right thing and also
I love how they just like I made it and
announced it like Amazon I was like four
years should we June there we go who was
it everyone like everyone was that are
like bidding like it's a [ __ ]
Olympics yeah and here's the thing the
thing is is that I really know like
little to nothing about City planning
about what it takes to run a big city
like New York I know nothing about
weather or like way to control mass
amounts people I know nothing about
pedestrians I know nothing about traffic
and there nothing about controlling a
major city but I know that just myself
and my iPhone we could do a better job
than what's been going on I hear you
sister let's say you became mayor okay
first five things you do first five
things I do is I reduce no offense
bikers and I actually really like the
idea of biking and if I was a little
less [ __ ] I would get on a bike
myself I would reduce the number of bike
lanes like there doesn't need to be half
the street for bike lanes on every
Avenue seem like Madison Avenue there's
two bus lanes gotta go then on first
time you there's bus lane bike lane part
two parking lanes on each I'm leaving
literally two lanes for cars goodbye but
then I will also make parking in New
York City way easier like there should
be garages on every roof of every
building like it could be so much better
than the way that it is now there should
be apps that are built that the city
uses to help build that show where
parking is like you shouldn't have to
just rely on parking on the street or
paying twenty five dollars an hour like
there needs to be a better way as we saw
with Alec Baldwin you know what I mean
it drove him to the edge like to throw
up him to get and then I would tell all
of the crossing guards and the traffic
control people go home go home you've
been released of your duties if you
would like to join another City industry
please let me know but you
is no longer a profession considering we
do have traffic lights and they work
they work just bad they work quite well
then why I'm really like enjoying
enjoying this I'm a manager to the
Destry and sidewalks pedestrian types so
like on random streets like stopping all
traffic and putting down a couple of
chairs and benches and not letting
people go oh oh gone
time squares random blocks of cement
with like a dirty chair on it that is no
longer a useable Street for driving it's
for people to sit and like take pictures
agreed
those are eyes are the first thing
that's gone and I actually think bike
lanes are really helpful especially
because like these days if I need a
delivery post mates over rush on a bike
will get it for me it's the fastest way
of getting on so let's make it easy for
the pro bike but also like bike lanes
are also like dangerous for Mike there's
like I would ride a bike if I could bike
on the sidewalk like I don't like live
there needs to be better like a bike
lane shouldn't be like a car lane do you
know no but also a bike lane needs its
own they don't follow red light green
light 1 2 3 like they think they're
above the law right oh it's not
literally knocked out by a bike the
other day yeah and then when I would
also do is like similar to the High Line
I would build like Express pathways
above the sidewalks because some people
I'm reading the commentary but keeping
the Express side with express sidewalks
abandon the sidewalks cuz some people
like you want to walk 20 bucks and you
don't want to get stopped by a light and
you're like charging by so I would make
it much easier for people to walk in the
city without having to stop every block
for a light stop because then also those
types of people they walk even when they
don't have the light and that causes
more traffic because people can't turn
yep so express I like Highline the city
and these random streets that are like
no right turn from 7:00 p.m. to 7:00
a.m. because I felt like it like why
right you make more traffic on other
streets right and then I would do like I
love the FDR I love the West Side
Highway I would do like a crosstown cent
well central highway that's like in the
middle like above Central Park that's a
highway if you just need to get you
don't have to go to the east to the west
side to get all the way uptown total and
then a couple crosstown highways ya know
the FDR and the West Side Highway are
inspired choices and they make living in
the city so much more livable
I couldn't use about 35 more of those
yeah so it's just where I'd start
and that's where the real drivers go
like they drive fast yeah cuz they're
they know where they're going
also I would literally just release this
is what they did in Israel and it's
pretty genius I would release like a
thousand cats Oh for them and track them
for a year and then a year later pick
them back up and give them out to nice
homes so that they ate all the mice
because the mice and the rats are out of
control
yeah and the cockroaches it's not good
it's not good so anyways it's just a
funny like what people think of New York
like bright lights big city I'm gonna
become a model I'm gonna move there it's
the city where dreams come true like
it's the only thing coming true it's
your worst nightmare um and then I would
also like go down to the DMV and like
bring them all donuts and just try and
cheer them up and what I didn't know but
a lot of cities in gear up they only
allow huge like 18-wheeler trucks to
come in between like midnight and three
delivery for deliveries and that is
[ __ ] genius because on a one-lane
cross street where a big-ass truck is
double-parked taking his sweet-ass time
making deliveries to Whole Foods that
should be illegal agree I think that's
so genius where they do in Europe also I
would create additional jobs by doubling
up the amount of Sanitation trucks and
workers and we should be doubling up the
amount of clean ups totally and like I
don't know what all of our tax payers
are doing because there's so much that
needs to be done and we live in a high
tax state so it's like wow there's a lot
to do when we have a lot of money to do
it but nothing's getting done so where
does the money go I'm genuinely curious
Amazon HQ $48,000 per place see like
just oversee their building it's you
paid X amount of dollars of taxes last
year here's what it did ya know I don't
know where's the accountability when it
comes to taxes I don't know no taxation
without representation anyways just a
thought they've been buying a story here
are the top ten searches on Google in
2018 girls no job do you want to start
from the bottom or the top bottom number
ten Kate Spade number nine Stephen
Hawking did you die yeah yeah yeah in
March 8
xxx 10th ASEAN there's a pattern here 7
Anthony Bourdain Oh 6 Megan Marco Oh 5
Black Panther for Stanley 3 Mac Miller
2 Avicii 1 World Cup
so Megan marquel is the only living
human on the list
Wow makes you think that's like really
not what I would have thought no not at
all and I actually would have thought
Megan Marco would be higher you know
because of like the wedding and and
being like so did you see her at the
British Fashion Awards like posing hard
with her belly I did the shoulders at
your nail polish and then she doesn't
give a [ __ ] yeah she broke the rules
about the nail polish um she looks great
stunning in the most annoying way yeah
all the drama is so crazy so I guess we
only care about people when they die is
what the lesson here yeah and the World
Cup
that's just like it's so funny how like
I live my life
the World Cup was also number one in the
u.s. first searches which is really
crazy that is really crazy like I live
my life with my head in the know I know
everything and I like probably think
about the World Cup like once every two
years never and honestly if you had
asked me did the World Cup happen this
year I wouldn't have known that it did
no if you ask me who played in the World
Cup or even who won Spain No take three
guesses
is it countries or cities countries
Madrid that's a city yeah right yeah but
um no okay
Germany no close-ish France yeah okay I
wouldn't get that France has the best
soccer team no I know that England has
good ones
Manchester mm-hmm and I fell Bend It
Like Beckham so I'm pretty well versed
in the whole Cup thing totally anyways
that's all she wrote you guys would
those are stories those are the stories
so I wanted to talk about real house
size up to Orange County and I'm so sad
that I didn't watch it when it was live
but people were giving it such bad like
reactions that I was like whatever I'll
catch up but I have a lot to say you're
not so interesting I you someone
watch things live because I wanted to do
like watch with two screens like using
Twitter but now I feel pressure to watch
things lies so I can watch with the
toasters in the Facebook group oh my god
a [ __ ] master thread of a lot of show
I caught the Busy Philipps one like two
nights ago with Kim what is so funny so
funny it's no there I'll be doing it
live or else you don't know what they're
exactly referring to but no like the
Facebook group has really taken the
place of Twitter for me I also in terms
of like breaking news no I mean the
Facebook group like I don't know if Mark
Zuckerberg has realized yet that his
platform is dying but the one like small
sign of life is groups I think that
actually he has because they've been
like it's not using their features yeah
I mean I can say and I know this a lot
for the toaster it's like they literally
only have their Facebook still like to
remember people's birthdays and to be on
the toasters yeah
so here's we're on that we're in Jamaica
it's like the first night and they're at
dinner and when Shannon was like no I'm
not rooming with Emily and like that was
so funny and Emily and Gina have like a
funny attitude about it they're like I
think Gina is actually like but heard
about it yeah but Emily's like it's
funny I actually love Emily and Emily
has an amazing body like you can't tell
in her like like businesswoman eternity
outfits but when she was on the zipline
or the whatever in her black one-piece I
was like guess bet you get it you just
had three [ __ ] kids that's okay
that's agreed on the reunion she
literally said she got that change so
much throughout the whole show people
calling her fat that she's like
unhealthy overweight disgusting blah
blah blah and then everyone was like and
she was like I hope I made up for it in
Jamaica like see I never was like you
look incredible if she looks so good
she might just be one of those people
who's like big-boned know if she's
gorgeous people who like looks bigger
and clothes and looks great in a bathing
suit wait that's so sad I really feel
like I think I'm a direct opposite I
feel like she didn't like being on the
season I feel like she might not come
back because I think she didn't have a
good time in there like it was make
trouble in her marriage yeah I think
that her her husband definitely didn't
come off great yeah I think she'll come
back just because she's poised for
success in the next but she's in but she
also doesn't need the show because she
is rich and works unlike has a real job
so I I think if she doesn't come back
it'll be because like people were tuning
in turn she couldn't handle like the
pressure on her marriage and that makes
me really sad cuz I really like her no
same I hope
and I wish I could have watched live so
I could have defended her yes that's why
I feel guilty but they were being so
funny and honestly that room sounds so
fun Emily g9 Kelly a hundred percent
it's just one of the tres amigos to
shamrit Anna and Vicki shall return um
since the beginning of the season let's
go together because production forced
them to all get along it's like it
bullsh and make it like the old time so
that the show looks good in a bikini
Vicki yeah I think these are six year
old women and they look better than me
like some of them [ __ ] time right
like we know but I just love I love
Kelly and I'm glad that whenever not
everyone would they Shannon got everyone
was like coming for her and they weren't
they were like in a really respectful
way just trying to like say like you're
not that whatever and she [ __ ] flips
have taken my mic off I need ten minutes
and I thought Kelly was gonna go to her
defense because like they are these new
best friends and I'm really glad that
she didn't cuz I think Kelly not doing
that make Shannon realize like oh I'm
the worst you know sort of sort of I
think Sean is still felt like they were
to speak meaning shatters like her time
to be the brunt
what's the complex today road complex um
persecution complex persecution complex
like anytime something goes wrong she
like thinks it's about her and like she
think automatically goes under the
defense and becomes the victim and
that's why it's so intolerable for
anyone to be friends with her and
honestly if Tamara's at her wits end and
Tamra has dealt with the most like no
one has any other reason you know yeah
for me like whether Shannon is this or
that doesn't matter like Tamra's been an
amazing incredible friend to her and
then like now has a life or death
situation on her hands and Shannon
didn't do the same for her and for that
reason I'm out on Shannon and child's
Madden connote can no longer exist in a
friendship that isn't completely
revolved around her own problems and her
own [ __ ] and everyone gets a grace
period like whether you go through like
a death or a divorce like you get a
grace period where you can act like an
[ __ ] and be a [ __ ] but everyone just
alludes it to the fact that you're going
through a hard time and they let it go
that grace period is very much over for
me that grace period was last season for
her yeah and ini excuse all of her when
she was yelling at Lydia I'm being so
even though you hidden Lydia she was
being so mean to Lydia I disagree Lydia
was being such a snake in the grass
trying to make up
Shannon and Vicki and inevitably Tamra
and Vicki and never leaving out Shannon
like no one would see that I disagree
whatever but yes last year what's her
guys paired she couldn't been going
through a worse time but now it's like
okay you picked herself back up you got
a house and it's like great you just got
$22,000 a month for child support
okay the house you're getting you just
moved into sold totally sucks imagine
not having the money to move like you're
fine
so she acts like her problems are the
worst problems in the world and when
Emily and Jeana and Kelly are like
literally there are people like who are
looking for their next meal like them
they don't know where it's gonna come
from and they have kids and they don't
know how to put food on their table like
stop looking complaining like in your
ivory tower you know that was like yeah
this what is this Ben what's wrong with
her like she should also his hire a
house manager I think that would solve a
lot of her problems because like she
gets really overwhelmed with like the
daily duties of running a household that
she never had to do before she just like
hired an assistant house manager who
like paid the water bill I think she'd
feel a lot better
she's also like a living warning but
like you can't let a man on your life
right like I I actually I'm the one in
the house where it's all the checks and
these bills because I have a lot of time
work yeah you can't let him in or notice
right run your life or room
I'm looking forward to the rest of the
chip in Jamaica I'm like really enjoying
OC now and I don't want to stop because
I usually like would play it while I'm
like doing something on my computer but
I mean I've been giving it my full
attention and it's quite enjoyable I
might say I'm so glad that you think so
and what was on my side Dallas Dallas
was up coming back up um okay so it
really was about DeAndre and DeAndre
really had to eat a lot of [ __ ] over the
reunion and like have to kind of admit
that she was wrong for things and it
kind of it ended in a really good place
but there was a really interesting
conversation between DeAndre and Cameron
about like Dallas society and it was
like so out of touch and all the women
like we're understanding I can't believe
we're talking like this and and and like
Kari was being so annoying she was like
you guys I can't believe we're talking
like this like we're like this is so
embarrassing they were like talking
about society like you're in it I'm not
like I'm in a you're not like this is
what society says and I guess saying
Society is like um I also went out of
touch were nowadays like Oh like talking
about society is like for class yeah
it's like a class system exactly and and
he was like no I am loving this because
it's really just like so crazy what how
people think and then can they were
talking about how stephanie was like I
had I thought I had so many friends
before the show and I did this show and
none of them ever spoke to me again like
her society friends and like a Dallas's
hi be like really looks down on the show
but then I think Deanna and cam coming
in really up to update um it was just
really really what are they saying about
the society the Kevin was like I don't
even like the word society blah blah
blah and then Cameron was like to
Deandra and you keep saying like I'm
married into it like as if I'm from the
ghetto and I was cry just like I'm not a
Seto it was and then Deandra was like
span like you can't talk about society
because you're not in it like bah bah
bah and what's really weird to me is I
okay there's society whatever but the
behavior that some of the women exude on
the show that would make Dallas society
look down on them I think that Leeanne
exudes the most of the bad behavior from
you know just have being angry and
shattering bottles and threatening to
stick around and like you know grinding
on the floor of the club like stuff that
makes for a great housewife but really
wouldn't fit well in society so I don't
know why they haven't shunned her do you
know what I mean yeah even though she's
barely like she's just in the charity
world that's the thing about all the
franchises is that they go into a city
looking for the most famous tight-knit
group of friends richest and more often
than not those aren't the people who
want the show right they'll refer like
their trashy friend and then it's their
friends and there's still upper-class
and they still wealthy ish but they're
not they're not who the show was
intended for yeah I think the only time
they really like hit the nail on the
head is in Beverly Hills kind of but in
Miami when they had like that was true
high class in Miami was like Larsa
Pippen Lea black that annoying dentist
KarenT you know no she was the reason
we're sign but like then they really got
the good inner circle you some some
she's just like strewn about
yes for sure I think Beverly Hills
things really like I think Kyle Richards
is really like a kingpin in Beverly
Hills like she's I think she's but yes
but I think she is now because of the
show but she was always like friends
with yeah yeah I agree the show it was
happened
I agree Lisa Vanderpump doesn't didn't
need the show doesn't need the show but
helped make the show buzzes camille
Grammer did yeah actually they had a
really good they've never had a poor
house wife except for Taylor Armstrong
yes
well did you hear a rumor that dude all
the Lisa Vanderpump drama last season
they are thinking of Brandi Glanville
coming back which I would personally I'm
here for it here for beyond here for it
she really needs it I wonder if her and
Erica would get along yeah I feel like
they might they both use the c-word and
they both don't like look to nitpick
like at every single fight like most
housewife fights star because either of
a miscommunication or like I can't
believe you said that one thing and then
they go back and forth as to whether I
actually said it like they both let
things roll off their back a little bit
more yeah I was enjoying that friendship
yeah you know I could really use back a
Carlton Gebbia not anymore cuz now she's
like divorced and oh yeah you shut those
cool parties we really need Heather
Dubrow not in the OC no that's because
if still they haven't filled that hole
like there's still no one that feels
like the Heather role
yeah like the moral high ground like hmm
but I don't think she would fit in well
with those ladies I feel like she was
sitting like her and Gina would get or
her in that I feel like she's fine she
really used to get along with everyone
which was so great are you talking about
putting her back at OC yeah oh it's a
minute endeavor no putting her back in
OC you know what I'm just doing so fine
without her I haven't even thought about
her that much this season I don't really
care for her
and did you see the drama between her
and Kelly dot and Orangetheory okay so
Kelly dad was pulling up to her gym
Orangetheory and she was like Instagram
story got headed by CEO Heather Dubrow
was outside didn't say oh my god
Heather Dubrow was outside the gym and
Kelly was like oh [ __ ] I don't wanna go
in and see her and talk to her so she's
like waiting wait he made me she's like
my class starts in five minutes
Heather don't you have a gym in your
house why are you here and then she
eventually got out of the car and went
to the gym I don't know if she said hi
but then a Heather started commenting on
Kelly's picture Kelly is a mess on
[ __ ] Instagram and Twitter agree but
it's great it's great for the show it's
just an extension yeah and xxx
concezione everything else we need to
recap before we complete no I've been
enjoying red oaks oh yeah one of my
application
oh yeah my application is almost done I
think we should send them in together so
please get me yours and I'll send them
in I mean I'll do that today what a
country club what else we have some
peach Rhine opposites to record so we'll
do that this week / weekend we're gonna
do part 2 taking all your questions
about drum about toast magetta and
toasts is what i'm calling it and that's
pretty much it you guys will be back
tomorrow with another fun-filled just
like the first time we've done a
straight hour we're always supposed to
be like a one-hour show
yeah and we're either like 45 minutes or
two hours right well I just wanted to
remind you guys that I'm headed to your
hometown we're headed to Houston we're
headed to Orlando we're headed to Tampa
Greenville South Carolina Greensboro
North Carolina Foxwoods which I believe
is almost sold out which is so [ __ ]
crazy Huntington New York and Long
Island buncha shows tickets available
girl with no job calm most of the shows
are either sold out or almost sold out
so I encourage you to get your tickets
now as opposed to waiting but even if
you can't I love you also Real
Housewives of New Jersey I'm two
episodes behind so we'll recap tomorrow
yeah it's pretty good
yeah no I know I watched the episode
where Jennifer and the new girl huh
yelled at Teresa like well do you think
your husband would still be in jail if
you could Jackie Jackie oh I haven't
watched that and I was like oh [ __ ] no
but she made a very fair point like
Teresa saying that Melissa can control
her husband okay so you control your
husband and you ended up in jail yeah no
not only that I really hate when people
get involved in conversations that
aren't that doesn't pertain to them but
don't have that conversation and grab
everyone 500 people on a show where
everyone is provoked and wants to get
involved so it's like if you really want
to have a conversation step aside no
from once you bring it to everyone
anyone can jump in and obviously having
known and met the ladies of Jersey
whatever Melissa and Mar just do or say
I agree with that because they're so
reasonable and they're so right I love
them so much we gotta get them back on
before the season ends we do they were
at a party the other night by the way
everybody Lee I was like literally I was
thinking about going but I just everyone
asking that young buck I mean like who
was like special who was there um well
so James Hendy was deejaying I met
Raquel she was really sweet um Margaret
Melissa and then I saw later Ramona
Oh Drennen John we're there Luanne was
there dude we're joined and John like
partying um it was still early in the
night I didn't stay very long okay I've
heard that they're partiers yeah they go
out til the break of dawn till the break
of dawn also Donald Trump jr. was there
mm-hmm which is like so crazy that is so
crazy a man has wives by the way have
you done any Christmas shopping I just
had to do my like Christmas cards for my
doorman and like dog walker so I broke
right now I'm in the process of doing
that you know what I did cuz like I feel
like it's you have to give money in New
York like there if you live in a
building there's doorman handyman
concierge Porter there's like 15 people
who like to make the building run and
make my life so easy and they're all so
nice and I'm like okay I would say that
they only want money and I did give
money obviously but I also wanted to
give like a summer so I found out where
each of them were from and I gave him
like a homesick handle from where their
frog that is so sweet I thought it was
like a really good idea yeah it was
really hard to find out where they're
from without like being super creepy
right but I was like hey Peter do you
know where Carlos is found some Queens
that's so sweet
yeah and then also I I got to give like
a bigger bag it looked like more steps
of an envelope in there with cash which
is I know what they really wanted but
then I went like another thoughtful
thing they like go out of their way to
make my life so easy like I have so many
deliveries and so many things going on
and I'm never [ __ ] there at the right
time and they're always picking up and
dropping eggs they take care of Theo
make sure he comes back from his walk
they really do like the guys in my
building like look out for me and I so
appreciate it they like they come to my
house and they're like [ __ ] set up
furniture but well I'm not even home I
mean one of them sent me up the service
elevator but it's fine but it was not
for that it's not now take them I'll
take them so I thought that was like a
nice gesture that's a great dress shirt
and right now our listeners who go to
home sitcom and use promo code toast
will receive 10% off any order over $60
and get free shipping
that's a great deal 10% off and free
shipping this amazing offer expires at
the end of December and the most popular
state and city candles won't last long
so don't wait just visit home save calm
now using promo code toast and find a
personal gift for your whole list today
they also make mini candles which I'm
obsessed with mini candles like I put
them around the bath and that's good for
like a stocking stuffer in case you
don't spaced or like the big whole thing
totally and speaking of gift ideas we
also will be doing a patreon episode of
our favorite things
Oh like Oprah yes what are a favorite
things you're gonna have to put together
a list and we're gonna do an episode
like your marriage I mean this is one of
my favorite things actually I love this
vest - I don't know how cute it looks on
the show today but in person you said
that vest was discussing in person it's
just like a cute little puffer no I'm
really a man I I just like love our
merch I can't stop wearing it and by the
way we make some high quality [ __ ] we
really did I mean now my toaster shirt
mi TMT lingo shirt are covered in
diseases because I like laid in them for
so long so I'll have to do a wash oh but
I finally got my washer/dryer fixed and
last night before I got into bed me and
Ben cleaned our sheets because we
thought like you can only get sicker if
you're like laying in your own filth and
I just have to say like and this is like
a not a novel thing for people who like
live in the suburbs and who don't live
in New York City but like having laundry
can change your life like in Vanderpump
rules when they opened James and rekkles
closet door and there was a washer dryer
they were all like and I'm sure so many
people were like what cuz every house
has a [ __ ] washer dryer but in in
these cities it's like you have to send
it out or go to the basement and I mean
operated to be able to do your own
laundry is a blessing and I'm so
grateful for it and when I moved into
the apartment the unit was broken and it
took a couple months to get it fixed
because the plumbing was all [ __ ] up
but I just I can't say how grateful I am
to be in a position in my life where
I've watched a dryer in my house like I
get to do my own lunch and not have it
like build up like Tina how exciting -
very I'm happy for you I'm happy for you
can understand okay so I'm doing my
panel today at alumni and sing a little
annoying cuz like I've to ask other
people questions but honestly I'm just
not up for it so I'm glad that it like
the pressures off I wonder if there's
any way like you'd seen your voice I
always forget that I'm like not 16 like
that's an inappropriate thing to say do
not ya know it's really crazy when you
think about like you're not 16 like no
because I just I'm gonna be back in
those halls and when I was in those
halls like I was boy crazy like I loved
boys and like I just minded dates and
like boys and kisses and now I'm like
a married woman and me talking to you
it's like I just I can just get arrested
for sure so I won't do it okay and maybe
you'll meet some of the Alumni maybe
someone age-appropriate there we get and
I got a list of all the people on the
alumni and it's like I graduated 28
weeks okay so I graduated in 2016 and
like everyone I was graduated like the
lady he's in the 80's and he's like I
saw one girl from 2000 that's so they
have like legit jobs one of them is like
SVP of Ralph Lauren I think uh maybe I
can make some connects it's big league
season one of them is a founder of like
one of the plated things
oh oh sure one oh hey I'm already taking
strides towards my new year's
resolutions I'm setting up times for
students and I to get our permits and
everyone is so annoying they're like
they're over 18 you don't need your
permit to get your license yes but you
need your permit in order to learn how
to drive and get on the road yeah like
if you're over 18 and you already know
how to drive you can just take get your
test I'm like really making shreds in
our whole country club lifestyle the
suburbs sing and I'm serious about the
car and I'm serious about getting my
license this year okay so I will get I
will to handle everything the lease look
at the car so we get we needed an SUV we
need like a mom car like a mom need like
an escalator something oh yeah the mom
those cars are double the price to park
because they take up so much space so
the biggest we could do was like a mom
car like mom Lexus that's a or mom
Mercedes mom Mercedes actually yeah
we'll see we'll say mom Infiniti mom and
dud the qat minivan Oh we can't roll up
to the country club like with our Chanel
bags in a minivan okay fine fine so I'm
gonna make I'm gonna make the
introductory steps to getting some
prices on a couple cars but we got to
figure out parking I'm gonna put out
into the universe if you own a parking
garage or if you have a building that
would let you park like I just I happen
to live in an expensive area that my
parking is $100 a day oh you know what
I'm gonna find that I live right guy
partner Isaac yeah I know what either
drive us to work everyday there's a
parking lot across here would you leave
the car here yeah well think about it
nice to bother not to bother you guys
with it so I'm off to my alumni event
follow me on Instagram see y'all to see
all the good times and also head over to
girl with no job comp to get your
tickets to the dirty jeans store before
they're all sold out have a great day
everyone
you